[Music]
hey what's up i'm her and this is
unfiltered
[Music]
i think music right now is what
something that we really need
um that we've we've been needing for the
past year is substance
you know um songs that feel good but
really say something meaningful and make
and reflect
um the way that we feel and the things
that we want
and the things that we need uh more than
more than what we want and i think
music is is taking that turn um so this
these songs of this summer is very
intentional i think that's what it is
it's intentional
and it feels good
the last year has been crazy i mean of
course in the beginning
uh the uncertainty was very hard
it was very hard and very frustrating
and
everything just stopped you know my
whole year was pretty much planned out
and that all came to a stop
but thankfully you know not too long
after
everything shut down i was able to stay
connected
and still and still
perform you know even though it was just
in my living room with me and my guitar
i was able to do lives i did my girls
with guitar series and created a
platform
where i could jam out with other girls
but also for new artists to be
seen and girls who play guitar to you
know show people like we're out here you
know we're rare but we're out here and
and that was just so cool so
um i really can't complain and i created
i can't breathe
in the summertime and then it won song
of the year so
you know there was there was a lot of
pain and anxiety and it turned into
a lot of blessings and it turned into
life lessons you know and
holding the people that i love even
closer and telling them i love them
every single day and
a lot of those lessons and a lot of
creativity was
found in the pandemic so i i can't
complain i'm
really blessed
[Music]
as soon as um they called you know the
nominations i was like oh wow i'm
sitting next to billy eilish and post
malone beyonce
and you know i think duolipo it was just
a lot of dope artists
that are killing it you know and killing
it mainstream killing it
and um i just didn't i didn't think it
was going to be me
i really didn't i didn't think it was
gonna be me and uh when trevor noah was
like
i can't breathe i was like oh my gosh
what
i was freaking out i was like no way
no way he called my song so that was
really special and unexpected and
yeah i can't believe it song of the year
it's huge
the thing about back of my mind is
it to me is a celebration of r b it was
important
to make a celebration of r b because r b
is so many things i think this album
will take you through the moods and also
it's my first official album it's not a
debut
for grammys and an oscar later but it's
my first
official album and everything has been
eps and i think the difference really is
like
you know the eps were just
small moments they were they were big
moments but but
in a period of time you know a period of
time
uh what i was feeling during that time
and kind of like
um a mood a specific
thing you know and those eps were
combined
um and they all represented something
different but this
album is my perspective of everything up
until this point
and it's so many different things it's
so many different emotions
um i hope people love it
well since i was born you know music was
around me
and my dad was in a band and he did it
for fun she's a cover band and they used
to play around the bay area but they
also rehearsed in our living room
and of course since i'm a half filipino
my mom
you know and and our family parties we
would have
uh karaoke so there was always karaoke
or there was always a band playing and
being from the bay there was just so
much music
happening whether it was like in oakland
you know a festival
or you know just there was always music
around so um
yeah i just grew up around it
[Music]
my mom's filipino my dad's black i
didn't think about it until
you know middle school and high school
is when you start figuring out who you
are and
there were times where i felt like two
asian two filipino for the black kids or
two black for the filipino kids
what that meant and not being able to or
not putting myself in a box because
people always try to do that
you know they need a point of reference
they need to put you in a category and
sometimes you can be all things you know
sometimes you can be
so many things and i think that that's
been my superpower and that's been
something that makes me really special
i just had so much good around me so
much good energy and so many people that
told me the truth you know about my
talent about
the possibility the potential of of who
i could become
in my career you know and and just that
i was
i was destined for something greater on
my first tour people were like
you know certain people were like don't
you know bring the guitar out don't
don't play guitar because
uh kids aren't gonna get it and i'm like
okay well now it's cool to play
instruments you know what if i
what if i compromised myself you know we
might not be where we are right now you
know i
i might not be where i am right now i
definitely wouldn't be
oh there's tons honestly uh rihanna's
been one of them lately i
i love riri and the makeup looks that
she does they always match because like
they she just gets it i don't know and
like i don't know
we have like similar skin tone so like
when a lip looks good on her i'm like oh
i think i could i think i could rock
that
sometimes i want to be a rock star
sometimes i want to look like lenny
kravitz another person i'm really
influenced by is prince um my oscar look
was his oscar look when he won and um
yeah i wanted to pay homage to him but
yeah all his looks like i'm like oh my
gosh the female version of that like
what does and sometimes he's wearing the
female version of it
already so i i love to pull from from
prince
[Music]
[Applause]
i think you know for the most part like
glasses that make
you know my i don't know that compliment
my face is
it's usually a certain shape but it also
depends on my
how my hair looks but um you know i i
designed these because i really like the
big glasses they just like make my eyes
i feel like look bigger i don't know
but um yeah glasses are fun i i think
you just gotta rock them like some
people
they like get glasses and they're like
i'm not really confident in glasses but
they look really good so sometimes you
just gotta take a chance
and wear them out and rock them and see
the reaction
sometimes as a woman we have
pressures of what a woman looks like
what it means to be sexy
and that sometimes in order to be sexy
you have to have your clothes off
and to me that's not the case you know i
think you can be sexy either way
and um yeah i'm all about the the aura
of it and not necessarily what it looks
like or
or you know how sexual you are but
maybe how sensual it is and how it makes
you
feel um and not what it looks like and i
think
you know um your definition of what it
means to be a woman or
how it means to dress is is up to you
and
and nobody else can take that away from
you or define it or put it in a box
it feels like you know i always say
everything happens for a reason
but i also realize that everything that
i'm doing is so much bigger than me
it's so much bigger than you know
accolades which you know
being recognized is so important and
being acknowledged is so important but i
realized that
these songs and and the recognition it
means
uh that i have literally been placed at
this time at this moment for a reason
you know to represent the filipino
community asian community
to represent the black community to
write songs that reflect how we feel
that really reflect how i feel and it
just turns out
you know it just so happens that it is a
reflection of how other people feel and
you don't realize that when you create
art you just do it because you love it